اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان انفجار
واقع في مدينه جانكوي في شمال شبه جزيره
القرم ادى لتدمير صواريخ كروز من طراز
كاليبر ان كان الاسطول الروسي في البحر
الاسود يعتزم استخدامها وذلك اثناء عمليه
نقلها عبر السكك الحديديه واوضحت اداره
المخابرات الرئيسيه بالوزاره ان هذه
الصواريخ مصممه لاطلاق بل للاطلاق من سفن
سطحيه تابعه لاصول الروسي في البحر الاسود
ويبلغ بداها التشغيل اكثر من
2500 كيلو متر على الارض
و375 كيلو مترا في البحر هذا هو اخر
السلطات القرم بوقوع هجمات اوكراني
استهدفت السككا حديريه وبنيه التحتيه في
شمال شبه الجزيره وذكر مسؤول برئاسه القرم
ان السكك الحديديه والبنيه التحتيه
والقطارات لم تتضرر وتعمل وفقا للمواعيد
المحدده بعد تفعيل انظمه الدفاع الجوي
مشيرا الى اصابه احد السكان بشظايا بسبب
حط ام هذه المسيرات
هذا مشاهدينا واعلنت ايضا القوات الروسيه
تدميرا معدات اوكرانيه باستخدام نظام
الصواريخ المضاده لدبابات ذاتيه الحركه
خلال القتال بالقرب من مارينكا وقال قائد
المجموعه التكتيكيه المضاده لدبابات
بايكال ان نظام الصواريخ المضاده لدبابات
ذاتيه الحركه يقوم باستطلاع الاهداف
والمراقبه لتحديد وتدمير مركبات العدو
المدرعه وغير المدرعه مؤكدا ان المجموعه
تعمل على منع دبابات العدو من اختراق خط
الدفاع مشيرا الى انه تم استخدامه صواريخ
اتاكا